walter and myron
walter and myron and fresh and fit
walter and meyer are absolute
heroes
i'll tell you why okay of course they
help with muscle of course they help
with money and helping understand money
but the number one thing that they do is
help young men understand female nature
and both men and women need to thank
myron and walt for exposing that amen
now it might not be at the same polarity
of a miami ho
but if a man understands female names
miami lady
no those girls are hugs bro
so but if a man understands this female
nature truly
the problem
in addition to mar in addition to mario
keening is actually management project
management
you need to understand female female
nature
if you understand female nature you are
more likely substantially more likely to
keep your woman happy because when she
texts you and she doesn't know why
and you crack back and she's like god
that was sexy i'll never leave
this man
i'm telling you
myron and walt are heroes
you're sort of like because i just
don't agree with this this this
that podcast i don't fundamentally what
is it specifically that you don't agree
with just like just the way they talk
about women the way this is the thing
it's just like if i'm going to learn
from a man like how
um they think or how um do you know what
i mean like just just learn in general
just from a man's point of view i i
like
the way that they
dehumanize women the the the terms that
they use like what issues
exactly things like hoes and all of that
kind of stuff and i just think it's like
what's all that kind of stuff though
sorry i hear you say hoes but what's all
that other kind of stuff
um they kind of don't like do you do you
think that they speak about women nicely
like do you feel that women speak on
their show they kind of like can be
derogatory sometimes nine out of 10
women on that show have an only fans
account where they sell nudes for money
okay but that doesn't mean that they
should be talked to anyhow or like but
it shows the type of character that that
that girl is because she takes the easy
way out does that mean you should talk
to talk but here's the thing
here's the thing i will
agree with you wait i will agree with
you that i do think they're rude at
times like i'm a polite person so
sometimes like they can be rude but like
they're helping men and that's that's
their end goal you can't i just could i
just take issue i mean i've been on the
show for a couple of times and i mean
justin's been on and sterling been on it
more times than me but i've been on a
couple of times i've known myron for a
few years and and like when you're there
i mean i i sort of fundamentally
disagree that they're disrespectful to
the women because actually they they
will they will always give everyone an
opportunity to come in yes you know um
and and if a male guest actually is is
talking too much so they'll they'll calm
them down and say no let her come in and
you and even when you see them before
the program and they're interacting with
the women and everything it's very very
respectful there's no sort of you know
that that because i mean apart for
anything else they know that you know
these women are kind of make what part
of what's making the show so popular but
they they i i would fundamentally
disagree that they are in any way being
sort of like deliberately derogatory
towards the women i mean what's being
displayed may appear derogatory but
that's often because of the way the
women are behaving yeah that's that's
the other thing oh no
well i think what you're mixing up is
the the message
versus the entertainment part
they've seen myron tell a girl
hey do you understand like in a way that
he kind of knows that she might
piss back at him yeah and then he can
boot her but that's the entertainment
side of that show okay that's what i
don't like yeah that's what you don't
like
messages it's the reason you're watching
it right yeah the reason most people are
watching that is true
that's it's the jerry springer of our
age
this show
but that is the unfortunately that's
human nature
look at why was jerry springer so
popular speaking to the mic sorry
but just a couple of things just like
you know um it's not necessarily human
nature because the you know as well all
in podcasts and stuff like it sits on
youtube so if you watch something then
you're usually going to be serve
something again so where is normally in
real life if you don't like a
conversation you can just walk away but
you know i mean on youtube it will just
continue to be surfing do people that i
don't i don't agree with that do people
walk away from like i've seen people
sitting there and arguing for hours
in person i don't think they walk away i
think yeah they do i mean yeah i don't
think people get the first fights
this fights would not exist if people
walked away from conversation
my point is just that you know it's not
it's it's it's kind of like an unnatural
way to con consume things like that and
i just think that
i i just have a real issue with it and
so where i'm making a face is because
it's my genuine reaction that it makes
me uncomfortable because i feel that
they
i mean some of those women are like real
you know the thing is it's more about
the audience right yeah the people that
are watching it and if they go out into
the world and then speak to women like
that as well or think it's okay or don't
understand like okay we can understand
maybe because we're in it and we're
exposed and all that kind of stuff but
the average person watching it they
don't necessarily understand that it's
just dramatization they don't get that
but there's a lot is wrong and i think
it's irresponsible
to continuously perpetuate that kind of
message but what are they what are they
they're not telling them how to like i
don't know what what have they
specifically said where they tell banded
like call women hoes or call women there
no but they don't have to do that what
it is is about uh just subtly repeatedly
putting in certain messages into their
content or talking to women in a certain
way and repeating that process over and
over again where it becomes the mourn so
therefore you don't have to say that
adverse statement you can just suffer
but that's you reading between the lines
though that's that's you like taking how
yeah like you can't say they didn't say
it but this is what they're saying but
but couldn't you say the same about like
you know hip-hop music and all that
stuff i mean is it isn't it just like
what are you saying well that
that kind of terminology was used a lot
particularly like 90s like rap and all
that kind of stuff i mean it's not right
eva
yeah but at the same time if you walk in
a club tonight
women everywhere are dancing and shaking
their ass to these hoes i'm
cheating on this and it's cool
when it's little wayne saying it's
totally true they're they're super about
i love it this is my blah blah blah
and then but then when it happens and
that's the culture that fresh and fit
yeah it's really much very much tapped
into is that you know
american rap culture so street kind of
and i get it so the lingo is attached to
that as a member of that culture it's
it's it's a bit much that's what i'm
saying i have a question for you have
you ever
really delved into fresh and fits
content do you watch it to a point where
you could say i understood their channel
i've watched their content because
what um some of the guests were saying
were
you're only seeing their content from
the viral clips and the viral clips of
the entertainment and that's the stuff
that
would be deemed and then but the thing
is disagreeable i i hear what you're
saying and this this argument often
comes up but then the thing is it's just
like well if everybody's not watching do
you know i mean like if everyone's
watching everyone's full content then
call them we have then we're on an equal
step you have context that's not that's
not the same thing and it's just like
you get these
headline
type stats and things like that that are
used to make points but i have to do a
whole thesis on this to make a point no
no no it's not a full thesis it's like
okay i just understand a lot where
they're coming i agree like sometimes
they're they're a bit rude for me like
i'm kind of i understand where you're
coming from but it's just
when you're running a show a lot of
times like there are times where i'm i'm
very rude to a guest and i cut them off
but it's only because they've
interrupted me 10 times
so i'm so unreasonable yeah
and
and so and so and as a as a show host
like it you you're very disrespected
because you put on all this time into
paying the producers you put all this
time into getting the guests you put all
this time and energy and effort just to
have a guest that keeps interrupting you
and so by the 10th time you're like
shut the up like that's what
most people do and a lot of times like
when their clips go viral like and i i
can't remember i wish i could quote it
off the top of my head but i can't but
the one like rapper that came in that
they kicked out that like went super
viral yeah it was because like he told
them like 10 times to stop talking and
then she like she wouldn't do it and she
showed him coaches
yeah and she showed up late like these
guys are pretty big for me
yeah these guys were pretty big guests
for my channel they showed up on time
and like it's just
you know and it's just like it's like a
level of respect and you don't always
see the context of the room
and i think that's that's something that
most people don't understand about you
know martin and walter fresh and fit
right they're personal friends of ours
we love them to death
and they have like their hearts are in
the right place yeah they really really
want to tell both men and women i can
tell you this as a man who knows them
personally all right but
again
to reiterate your point that is
like
if you
people have so much entitlement in
today's day and age they really do like
oh i got invited on fresh and fits
podcast oh cool i'm gonna rock up late
drink all their alcohol
be have my social medias blown up by
their
a million subscriber audience have all
my only fans account blown up by their
million subscriber audience which does
happen we know it happens right and
they're still
gonna
talk speak out of line be disrespectful
to myron because he said something they
don't agree with they're gonna be really
rude to him and try to talk over the top
of him right not obey the house rules
like a producer here kind of laid down
before similar thing right
it comes from this place of entitlement
it's a real lack of respect
those are the women that they're
inviting on there i don't know how you
guys can say and they're your friends so
i feel i i'm giving you a lot of grace i
think you're blinded by your friendship
with these guys but if they are really
trying to help men
why do they have such a set type of
woman that comes onto their shoulders
and then and then be so horrible to them
when you're really trying to help men
when a lot of these men
have real problems with women in life
like they have problems relating to them
and then you have these women who are
represented of the beauties and they are
allowed to cuss them do you not think
that actually allows these hermits in
their in their bedrooms with their mum
upstairs feeling like i can do this to
women as well so i i actually understand
a little bit like how recruiting works
and the thing is again as i said in the
beginning of the podcast it's not a good
pod
podcast if you don't bring on
opinionated people with a conflict of
ideas so when when you're recruiting and
i'll say this like fresh and fit they're
they're women on their show are not
representative of all women and i know
this from recruiting that's why i say
polarity yeah yeah but it's because like
when you're trying to have a battle of
ideas you want two people on the
extremes as much as you can like this
would be boring if if we all agree yeah
boring yeah like this is great this is
what we want but we can still have like
respectful dialogue
yeah we have and like you guys have been
great guests like you've been super
respectful and you showed up on time
like you you did everything i could want
from a guest but sometimes
i'm telling oh god these these girls
these ladies
they'll interrupt you a million times
they'll show up late they'll like
they'll but they had a girl on the other
week when i when i was on it they had a
girl on and she was um
she had studied at an ivy league and she
was uh very liberal and she you know she
had a very feminist perspective and
everything like that and i don't i don't
i mean i don't know maybe i'm just you
know i don't know biased or whatever but
i i didn't see them treating her with
disrespect they allowed her to speak
they allowed her to make her points you
know she wasn't the architect i mean i
think she was probably she'd like to go
out and party or whatever but she wasn't
that archetypal you know kind of fresh
and fit type girl really and um yeah you
know so i don't think
like you're presenting it like they're
just going for the you know the most
egregious examples of that sort of
stereotype but i don't really think that
they are and i i think they have them on
a lot
but i i i absolutely do get what you're
saying um
from my experience with myron like i
started a a youtube channel that i i
only do it part time
and
before i started i said to myron like
what do you think on this idea do you
think it's a good idea i knew it was
someone that was going to give me the
truth it was someone that was i saw
always modeling to to men and women the
truth of things so i thought right okay
i'm gonna speak to him
and he was so respectful he said you
know do you have any more questions how
else can i help you like very different
to probably what you're seeing on on the
podcast right completely different
person really respectful checking in how
you doing what's happening
and
yeah i would just say that he did say
things to me like you know how old are
you and i was really concerned because
you know i'm not a young creator and i
thought
that's going to hold me back and he was
like telling me the ways that i could
maybe get around that
and my my my experience
of him was nothing but like respectful
yeah because what they're doing is
they're a lot of these guys that watch
this show they do come for the red meat
but the genius of fresh and fit the
genius of walt the the genius of myron
is that they're selling these guys what
they want
but the undertone message is giving them
what they need bang
and you have to understand for the guy
that's in indiana and he's 18 and he's
probably a bit immature and he likes to
see the drama
he's seeing that
but when he goes to let's say he gets
married let's say he actually gets
married
when he goes and he watches fresh and
fit he learns about hypergamy and female
nature which is one of which is the
untold pillar that a man needs to have
in his life on top of normal
competencies
what malt what walt and myron are doing
is with extremism showing that young man
in that flyover state in america
what to look for in that woman he
marries in indiana and how to make her
stay happy and how to keep the frame
with her because he understands female
nature now are they doing it with big
glaring red flags and fireworks and and
wwf wrestling yes but without that
they will not tune in and for that
reason they cannot save those young guys
lives and
i argue and i really mean this not only
are they saving the young man's life
they're saving the woman's life and
they're saving the life of those
children amen